to
ah here we go again I fixed some stuff Senpai so it should look better on your
side
go high yeah it should look better on you your side yeah yeah yeah I can't
remember what happened last time I can't remember what happened last time Senpai
where are we supposed to go west
talk okay hope he's doing okay what's that west or east or not east or we
that feeling when you we don't remember which way this is what happens when you
play like two RPGs at once your mind starts to become
monkey various ruins blah blah is there a drone to check hold on I could check
no that's not it
no
okay I think we need to go back into the castle and just be like hi
okay which way are we going western when you need to rest look for a naming
gaff at the western guard house okay not that one um do we need anything in the
abbey I don't think so I just wanted to to get rid nice stuff okay here's the guy
again they say proceed to the guardian temple with the princess to ask for God's
will and take good care of the princess she's the only remaining descendant of
Aldehyde oops I said the bomb there that was my bad here let's talk to him
again okay you can count on me yeah that's nice where was I supposed to go
oh
take good care of the princess accidentally explodes yeah that's what
happens don't trust me with anything you asked me to take care of people I'm
gonna not do a good job at least to the eye of a rather normal person
oh we can we actually have donations oh my gosh we can actually donate hey you in
the mini skirt have we met before I feel like I know you leave this fate I'll
survive this long to meet you that's the queen sass that's the queen sass I was
I didn't think they were actually serious about the 600k
I didn't think they were actually serious but I guess they are it's I wish I had
that kind of money
I remember them saying it was like past the mountains or something
it might be weeks it might be this way
never eat shredded wheat that's how I remember it
that's how I remember my direction sort of
I can't remember what I was supposed to press oh yeah this thing this is so dumb
and here in the middle of me doing my radar thing should I move over some pie
so that you can actually see the mini map there we go over here
that's the volume by the way I'm not sure if the volume is good for my some
pies I am good okay I can make a big map too okay I can't remember how to do
that I think we're very close I see something here oh are you this the
mountain path I think this is correct
let me look at the sign watch out for trolls when you're attacked do not
engage in battle let them pass focus on protecting yourself for a while wait we
had a book I think trolls don't like the light
I think that's what they said
bomb bombs away that's a nice ow ow you're a hole
a troll
huh that's that's that's a troll
they said focus on protecting ourselves so maybe we guard and then I can do what
was this one again what zero
okay can we one
Um, no.
I'm prepared to die.
Jesus!
We are going...
Back!
Hold on.
We're doing this again.
I'm going to go read about trolls again.
Thank you.
You
I can't catch up with that.
I can't catch up with it.
With it.
Did I practice it? I only practiced a little bit.
I only practiced a little bit.
I did. I did. This part was the little bit part.
It wasn't part.
That was the part I practiced!
I found the notepad mistake!
And I found the notes by mistake.
I think that's where I was supposed to go, maybe?
I don't remember.
I'm actually serious about going like, oh, where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Is there anything mercy can't do?
I can't whistle.
OK, hold on.
I just need someone to tell me where the fuck I'm going.
Pretty sure I was right.
Oh, fuck.
Down to hide, hope for the concerns, blah, blah, of the citizens, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, doob.
Everyone's gone.
Maybe it is the mountain pass.
Oh, let me go back to the night saw.
The night's thingy and then reread that book.
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to just guard and just cry.
That's a huge possibility.
Hi.
By the time being, we are using the guardhouse as emergency lodging for all travelers.
Please understand, we do have the charity for lodging here.
Wow.
Thanks.
Anatomy of a demon, that's not right.
It should be over here.
Troll control.
OK, massive physical strength, great survival skills, faced with a troll.
If you're skilled, feel free to fight.
It's because fear is light.
One flash may lead to victory.
Troll is cautious and careful.
Leave troll alone.
Got it.
Defend the fuck.
OK, we just defend light magic.
Did you see what happened when I did light magic?
Shit awe.
Beagle zero in red too.
It was big red.
I felt insulted.
It was like looking at a test again, a test mark that I got back in like grade school.
I was like, oh cool, I have light magic.
Let's use that.
Yeah, I have light magic.
OK, it's time to face.
As if you ever got a single zero on a test ever.
Um, I sure did.
It's because I think the flashing ones.
Yeah, you did.
Yeah, I've gotten to zero before.
I may be somewhat academically skilled, but I have been granted zeroes before because
they just didn't like me.
For what subject?
Um, I got a zero in art.
It's kind of subjective, it's kind of a subjective, subjective thing in art is kind of a subjective
thing, which I thought was kind of dumb.
Which, did you just not turn the incitement in?
No, they just didn't like what I did.
It's got a zero because I didn't like what I did.
Oh, sorry, I need Rudy here.
Give me your stuff.
Hopefully, this hits.
No, OK, we guard until it runs away, right?
That's not a troll.
That's a lizard man.
That's a different guy.
Shoot.
The fire beats most people, right?
Yeah, we can take these guys.
Shoot.
Gun strong.
Gun.
Me like gun.
I knew it.
That means I just have to go here.
Shoot.
Kill.
Set on fire.
It's always Jack who's getting destroyed.
OK, he deserves it.
Yeah.
Give me my level ups.
I want my bomb to reach.
Hold on.
OK, hold on.
Ow.
Fuck.
I get up up there.
I get up there.
I'm out.
I jump.
OK, that's the troll.
Guard.
Do not shoot guard.
Guard, guard, guard, guard, guard.
Please leave me alone, you scary.
Guard, guard, guard.
Thank you for leaving.
Kind of scary, not going to lie.
I can't reach, but you know, maybe, maybe I do have to change it to Cecilia and be like,
the flames of love.
How do I?
Wait, yes.
Shoot, yes.
Tack, yes.
Fire, yes.
Ow.
The tentacles are making things hard, and I have to kill this thing.
maybe there's a secret hole see maybe it's like trial and error bird nice bird date
fire how did you miss how did you miss do you see how big this fucking bird is how
do you miss 69 nice you open it yes
fuck ow seriously how do I I can't get up here there's some kind of secret way
to get up here rain no think right now oh shit oh we're good
my bit is not doing very good maybe if I can
wait what did I hit that was not that was not fire damn you know you can't do
anything without magic
my my my vitality is going to hell
no nothing
guard okay I may need some help senpai's how'd I get to this sec how do I get
rid of the this thing sprint through the door he's run away
apparently the boxes I destroyed you can throw them at the plants
oopsies oopsies that was my bad I was so excited you know so what I do do I
like how do I pick them up oh like that okay I draw it here yeah oopsies
I literally was like I love bomb sword this a strong power or feeling is emanating
from the old sword
act just thousands of people's feelings through the rusted sword obtained fast
draw strike buddy strike buddy is a fast draw technique the old handpan to
accurately hit an enemy using it with accelerator expands the target to one
enemy group so I can kill things now
so I can do that okay let's test it out I'm gonna test it out
let's go you little wire you little rat
oops bye bombs
it's another way here let's go this way
Has to be a trap or something that was my bad
and they're so nice and gave me an extra I wasn't facing the right way maybe I
should wear my glasses
you mean my vitality back there's so close to the edge
ah there it is well well it's kind of hard to see what the hell why I use this angle it's so weird
fire PK fire
Wow what a sturdy guy
Good good and if that doesn't work fire
oh
Keep hitting until they die
Yeah, that's good enough right oh
It's so hard to see sometimes I think the 3d makes some things pretty good and some things just really awful
Yeah, fuck it up
Well, we have like little MP what happened to my MP it's like gone
How's my motion sickness good because I turn the camera
Extremely slowly if you didn't notice some pie the way that I turn the camera is like so very slowly
I
Can it turn faster I'll close my eyes and show you
Yeah, oh
I do this very very slowly
I
Think jumps my great deal
I'll get that treasure
Nectar her nectar
I have to go around again, I think
Got ambushed
Honestly, I think Cecilia looks really cute in like this new
Allie
And this new travel outfit, I think she looks really cute
And happier
Allie Cecilia plays
Please heal yourself
Never mind
Goodbye my vitality
All
My vitality is gone
We guard
The troll is scary the troll is scary
There's only one change that they made to this version that I hate they took away a character's unique music theme
That's always a shame
I
Never played the first one so this is a version so I
Never
Never played that version before you know
Okay, hold on I gotta take off my glasses
I think I need to ask the optometrist to loosen these glasses because they pinched the side of my head really tightly
I
They're very uncomfortable
Ow
Are they plastic or metal glasses metal
Luckily I get like a free
Rechain changes I need a girl to heal up
Wait, did she she just like hit them?
Yeah, let's have a heal berry for you, babe. I
Was surprised she like she just like hit them
Metal you can adjust for yourself. You don't if you don't trust yourself not to break them. Just spending gently I
Sell them for a living. Oh, we got an optometrist in the house
Can you see this far away? Can you read what's on the screen?
I
Kind of cool just to hear about wait
Wait, how am I supposed to go down? Oh
Hello, I supposed to go down
I
Was a shitty ladder
Who built that it doesn't even work
I
Maybe I need to activate something first like your heart
Looks like there's a thing in any oh do I have to leave then
Break buddy
Oh
Those four corners look weak like the foundation of mine
Can't
All right
Ah
Welcome in welcome in
Welcome in welcome in Kendra. Thank you so much for the raid. Hello. My name is Mercy mode each from violor
Get one and dodge place. It made you today. We are playing
I
Give me a moment. I got a I got a loading circle on my forehead right now
Wild arms after Kodak
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
Optical death on the ps2
On a regional hardware. What's the physical copy a real copy of it?
What happened to the cute mustache dude from mr. You see
Mercy again in another mario stream
Yeah
My fit is back
How much did the game cost to me?
free
to uh other people uh
A lot more
I got a wonderful friend
No
No, he'll gave me this
I set these on fire
I need to get uh, do I need to get the boxes again?
I need to get the boxes again
Maybe gonna do a line of bombs, okay
My first thought was immediately like I have to
I have to throw boxes at it
But my friend gave me like
My the entire collection because she's she's uh
She was downsizing everything
I was like you're a streamer right here have my games and I was like no shot
Ha ha ha
SR SR
Oh
Wait, is this the wild arms girl where the girls pull a giant gatling gun out of her dress?
I don't know. It's the first time I'm playing. I'm still at the beginning
Oh
No, I was trying
Maybe I am a little pawn
A
Little maybe just maybe just have a shot
You're supposed to be a that's a cute part of you
Hi, we love that about you mercy. It makes you so cute. Where is that?
Ha ha ha ha
It's almost a compliment me about my charms
I
I'm using the bombs and pie is this right?
Please run away. This troll is kind of scary not gonna lie
It's goalie elsis it's a terrible thing
I
Am I supposed how many bombs am I supposed to use?
Is there just another path
Have we gone through the first door yet? Oh finally it didn't miss
Ow by this bird got a b-soul bird
Today I really wanted
Today I really wanted to like dress up like Rudy and show you guys in me like tee look at me
I'm Rudy
And then
It found out
I found out I have a lot of layers in my hair and I couldn't get
Every single layer to change the color of my hair. There's a lot of layers
Like an onion or a cake or a parfait
Hey
Our face are delicious
And I'm gonna have a big red headband
How many layers uh too many I couldn't find them all
Open the treasure box
Got a gimmel coin yeah
Is there another path I think that might be the only path senpai
Is that for the one up there and I don't know how to get up there
There's a path up there
This this way I just not see the path am I blind oh yeah, I'm just blind
Up things that was my bad. Oh, we're leveling up so much senpai
That critical did nothing nothing
I'll reload
We're just leveling up. Yeah
My first instinct is to throw
Wait, maybe that area I could actually have bombed
SOS FF
Skills are special abilities that can be added to each character skill must be equipped to work
They don't work by carrying them
After selecting skill in the main menu select the character
want to equip then
The skill menu will open each character has ps points
Skills can be equipped if the character's ps points meets the requirement for the skill
Also, when a skill is unequipped your ps points will be lost
Different skills to a character depending on the situation. Okie-dokie. Let's go
Up on
Here you go. Where are you Rudy?
Wait does that mean I could have uh just broken all those boxes over there
Shit, there's nothing
No items
No items just destruction the way I like it
What does it do though? Oh, I didn't check what it did
I just I just went yay things make this yay things and stuff. I should probably check
I
Got too excited. I got too excited thinking about boxes and maybe that there will be stuff in them
Fp is raised to 100% when near death
It's fine, right
I want that hemp on get out
Thank you
You
Yeah, we'll shoot whoever
Now we get this ugly bird left big giant bird. I don't know how they always miss but they always do
Here have this
Thank you, I didn't want it
Oh
There's several of them
Give me my treasure
Lucky card
1,500 gala I can update my gun
Goodbye food
Okay
Hey
Oh
That's so freaking rude
That was a rude ass biatch
Ambushed
Oh
That was a lot, huh
All I can think of when now making like money is how am I gonna get the arms
Give me my gun. Give me my gun. Give me a better gun for my gun
Wonder if they're gonna introduce quick travel
Still up for the gun fund
You
The rigid on game had a spell that let you teleport to any town you'd already visit. Oh good. I didn't want to like do it again
No, there was another bird. I didn't realize there was another bird
Making you yawn I get a little tired sometimes
It's not that I'm bored or anything it's just that I end up being super exhausted
After getting a lot of work done
I need my boxes so I can kill these plants
Oh
And I work do you do this is my work
B tubing is my work, but there's some things behind the scenes that I do
Ah shit
I'm so glad it takes only two
Mist
I missed go back in
Ah, I knew it
I'm running low on mp
But you stop hitting me
You
Re
You know what I'm starting to hate these plants these like Brussels sprout looking plants. I don't like them
Defend one
Walker
What do these girls do
No lefying physical attack
Yeah, sure jack you can be the simp
And Cecilia
You can be
You can not get hit
Going to the guardian temple make a break at the resort count of melama to relieve your fatigue
Melima melama remember to check your map after you go through the mountain path
Thanks
You made it
I want to go to resort city is there a casino?
Is there a free casino
It looks like an island there can I go there?
At the resort
Not this guy again
Don't hit him with magic don't hit him with magic don't hit him with magic
You
Thank you
Yeah, I got nothing fuck
I hate that guy he eats my magic like it's nothing
I hit hard now, so that's okay
What was the button that I had to
Start no
Select okay
I want that
I make the map bigger
Okay
Oh
Bird nice
Man
Do not fucking steal my shit. I will show you
Like that
I
Don't like the scan function the scans function kind of sucks
And how do I get in I go
You
Welcome to melama the town blessed by the guardians temple we are known for our delicious water
Delicious
Water
Our wine is also something not to be missed. Please try a taste at the nearby bar
Welcome to melama the town once full of fluff followers from the garrians temple
Iron town is known for its
Nutrient rich water go make your skin ultra smooth
Just take a look at all the elders here in town. They have no wrinkles or blemishes on their faces
Welcome to melama the water town
This ancient temple town is surrounded by water and blessed by the guardian. Enjoy our your tranquil stay
Everyone else you don't want some water you have some raw water rudy enjoy your stay
Although it's true though, like there's a lot of places where water tastes like shit
Great day isn't it? What can I get for you?
What's that toy hammer? I want a toy hammer
Only 10 toy hammer do
Memory pens nullifies negative effects
And
Status amnesia by one level
Uh, that sounds like something that requires work
Poor little Sadie lost her turtle. Her father didn't know what to do. So he told her it ran away back to sand river
I don't think she believes him. You're crying about her missing turtle all the time
I guess Sadie I put her doll everyone in town is looking for it, but there's no sign of it anywhere
Okay side quest find a doll
Don't like to see a little girl cry. So I've been looking every day. I've
Even searched the water
Uh canals are gonna be I don't think we're looking too far away when the doll may be right in front of us
Bird
Oh, would you like me to save your progress?
Yeah
Can you believe it? We've already done 10 hours of this
Wrong with being into books I think I'm much more thoughtful than those muscular guys with their nice tans
I do not partake in any physical activity. I love to write
It's pleasing to see a girl enjoying my poem or novel
If this true senpai is anyone here a viter
Tall handsome people like you with six pack abs would not understand my problems. Well, please stop calling me a twig
I don't know about you, but this sprite really makes him look super muscular
Oh
Like not gonna lie look at this look at those polygons
That is not a twink. You cannot tell me that's a twink
Oops
Wait, there's things there's a treasure chest there. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it
I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it. I want it
Official mercy modi's twink rating. I feel like people don't understand the art of twink anymore
I
Feel like nobody understands the art of twink anymore. I don't understand what a twink is
When they say twink they mean a twunk
My turtle my turtle is gone
My dad said that my turtle went back home to the sand river in the northwest
But I don't believe him. My turtle misses me as much as I miss it. Please. Please. Will you help me find my dear turtle?
Okay, leave it to us. We will bring back your turtle as soon as we find them
This turtle is a new yo turtle. It's all from the bar owners while they made for me
My turtle would never go northwest to the sand river alone
Turtle is a new yo turtle. Okay
Okay
Try to get into the canal somehow
Don't eat people don't eat the turtle it's cute
They're like a hidden staircase here
What's this? It's a veal
Oh, it's too much for a person to move all by themselves. Okay, that's something we come back to later
Oh
You cannot proceed any further because of the water dog. Let me talk to the dog
Did it bark oh it barks it barks
Welcome I specialize in water fire and water magic
What kind of magic do you prefer pack or support? I don't think I have any more crests, but if I do I would grab everything
Can I steal this boat? I want to steal this nice boat for my own
So
Looking in
Maybe going to rest up
One of the crest sorcerer spells is called quick and it increases the reaction time of everyone in your group
It's quite effective if used with members who have fast draw technique
I'm giving in a shot
If I had any crests I would but I don't
One thing after another I'm busy day. Well, hello, can I help you? Okay, launching just one. Okay
I
Need I need
I need lodgings. I know it's expensive
But I needed it
I don't all in faith in nature. Would you like to read it? Yes
Each guardian is lord of an elemental power that is capable of manipulating
They create sweeping torrents earthquakes, even tornadoes
The people of Fugaya have learned to live with these powerful energies as they are a necessary
Sahari part of nature
People learned to fear and respect the awesome powers of the guardians. However, respect and fear eventually becomes worship
This faith is found all over Fugaya in temples built for guardians
Nice I stole their stuff
I stole their stuff
Okay
What if I talk to this guy and be like, hey, help me drain the water
I feel like it's over there. How do I do it?
Can I go in here?
Dog no, that's a cat never mind. I'm I'm I'm so stupid
The book is titled skill lessons. Would you like to read it?
PS points are rewarded as your level increases and with these you can equip a variety of personal skills
These are two important points to remember
First you will need a specific amount of PS points in order to equip a personal skill
Second, even though even with enough points, you cannot equip duplicates of the same skill
For example, if you qualify for multiple xx resistance and have enough points, you are still only allowed to equip one
But if the same skill type have different names i.e. xx resistant one and xx resistance two you can equip both
In this case xx resistance one and xx resistance two combined to make xx resistance three
The efficiency of editing skills is up to each player
Thanks
Hi
I hope the rumors about out of hide being attacked by demons is not true
But we all know the saying where there's smoke, there's fire. I hope it's not true
Our late priestess put a lot of effort into spreading and cultivating this town's belief in the guardians
Look at his son though. He has no intentions of following his father's wisdom. Such a shame
Abundance of water includes the town is full of happy people. I feel fortunate to be living in this town
I'm about xx resistance. Nobody is resistant to xxx
Nobody is resistant to that not even you
I see it it's right there
I
Oops
You may can turn this little wheel no
They must have sound hella hella guidebooks
I
Did I miss a building? Yeah, that's my question too. Did I miss a building?
This is awfully small, isn't it?
Oh
The one with the crest shop can I enter that one? Oh, yeah, there's a door at the side. Thank you
I'm an armsmeister extraordinaire, but don't ask me about anything else
Ha oh, yeah bullets easiness critical
Uh critical
Our bullets
Hit our bullets
Bullets
I I only hopped bullets
Goodbye my money
This is my
Ah
Since my wife left me I found out that it is much tougher to take care of kids than it is to take care of arms
My daughter does not understand any of my logic, but just cries over trivial matters
God my wife why couldn't she have taken our daughter with her? What a guy?
I shouldn't have bought from you you piece of shit
I shouldn't have bought this from you. I could have gone back to town
Besides the glass case is a highly polished medium-sized arm
Do not say base. I will ban you or hit at least hit you very very hard
You
Mods
You know what to do
Gosh cat
But there's another one over there what the hell there's so many
Drum is filled with water seems like a lot even for this town
There's another one there
He's a shitty dad why didn't the mom take the kid with her they're both shitty parents
No, can I not send
I
Please let me in
I want to go around
So we'll lend me a boat
So
Please give me your boat. I want it
Did you have anything else in here books I can read things I can steal
The llama
But I want to get the little girl stuff
I want to get her turtle
Am I seriously not allowed to get her turtle my bard from having that happen
You
Turtles in the canal maybe all we need to stop by you mean the map that's not the map
They said northwest
Not this
I was out of town. Oh was it?
Why that's self I don't know directions, okay
It's very difficult
Although I am technically directionally challenged. I remember when I lived in Japan
I would always cry I would always cry a lot because I always get lost on the on the trains
I got really lost in a train station before
Because the train station was like a mall and I couldn't find the other side
What the fuck are those
I
Need an aoe
They call it an aoe where you hit everything
Thank you for the 420 tip anima
Junkie one two three. It's nice to watch a streamer live. Do you not often get to watch streamers live?
There's always the vods, but people are like
um
There is a little bit of something special to see something live
Can I come live
No work makes it hard to watch. I'm glad you could drop by then. Thank you
You
In our I came from the cave
I
Did I come from somewhere else?
This the cave that I was before no the cave was further than our
I was probably new then go in sand river
You
This where I'm gonna find the dang turtle is that a fucking monkey
Oh, that's a big guy. I hope it dies quickly
Oh
That's that's a lot. What the fuck
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh that hurts
Oh, oh, oh that really hurt. Oh what the fuck
Yeah
Anyways, that's a monkey
Wait, there's just a monkey here doesn't do anything
Is it do anything monkeys are cute
I feel sad because I cannot talk to monkey and I really want to
This is treasure box solidly locked. Of course it's using my break
Bombs away
Used radar
Radar is a machine that detects hidden passages or devices
By pressing square button you need to find something you are using to utilize it. Thank you for
So how do I use it? Do I have to equip it?
So
That's the button to change characters the left trigger
There's how do I use this tool?
There's another button to switch my stuff this is the run
Well, Rudy's luck is bad
This
Thank you
Oh
Me lightning will work
Yes, goodness
Yes, good good
Thank you though, thank you
Oops
Okay, I see them but how do I like
Get to there
I
Like it shows us like the hidden items but not but not um
Not like a cool path, you know
I fall I did fall
Monkey, do you know anything do you know anything about this monkey?
Should I go back to town is that what it's hitting to me?
Like the scan move show I hit it in path
But all I see is the items and not a hidden path
Maybe I'll go back to town I'll go back to town
Oh
Can half-time cross it that's true
I forgot about handpan
I forgot about handpan, how can I forget about our handsome pants pants?
Now I don't think it's working
If I stand on the edge here, no
No, I don't think so. I'm just gonna go into town
Back into town again and see if there's like hidden paths in the town
So
Surprise we're here to kill you
Like I'm a hundred percent sure the scan tutorial showed us things back in town, so we should go back to town
I don't know if you can hear it, but the ps4 is so loud
We will return for the turtle or maybe the turtles already there do not do not only hit
Do
What do you mean ps2 shit, what did I say?
Did I say p nice a psn or something yes for shit
Oh
Oopsies, oopsies even numbers get mixed up. Whoopsies
I honestly actually it was the other day thank you some pies by the way for the some pies that
I
There's something there
In path
So
I just see a treasure, but is there tells you the hidden paths, right?
I don't see any paths
The heck
Past the ladder I I know this ladder
But I'm trying to find like they're hidden mechanics
Where's the hidden path stuff I see the treasure but not the path
Maybe it has to be used in a building yeah, I'm gonna use it on this one
Okay
Oh as I was saying I was buying some games for the ps4, uh
I bought uh, what was it called? I think it's called
anonymous cold
for the ps4 thanks to the
The game fund that some pies
Oh we found it turtle here you go you go kid turtle isn't a real turtle
I
Hold on I got this
Oh, hey, that's my turn I can't believe it was it was there it was under her bed
You found it. Thank you the bar owner's father who used to be the priest
Of the guardians temple made this for me. This turtle is filled with the power of water guardian. It's my treasure
I'm so happy. I'm never alone as long as I have this evening when my father is away
Great. Oh, what was I saying? I was gonna bring my ps4 down. I
Did you know there's a lot of games?
um for sale on the ps5, but the
PS5 is kind of expensive
Uh, so thanks to the funds that some pies have given me. I have spent some money on some games
I'm hopefully after you finish these games that hope that will hopefully, uh, pick up and maybe finish together
So I picked up anonymous cold and I picked up, um
They picked up, uh
a bunch of a bunch of it okay
a bunch of air
and
I picked up, um
Some pointing clicks as well
It's great to see Sadie's got her doll back
I remembered what the bar's owner father the priest at the guardian temple used to tell me
Told me to hang a pair of scissors upside down when items were lost
Scissors, huh?
Well, kind um may have some uh days
Scissors also scissors mentioned whoo hang a pair of scissors upside down
The start is not for a random swinging, but it should
Penetrate the vital spot of your opponent with one swift accurate swing
You increase your reaction your fast draw will become much more powerful
Oh, I can just talk to him
I
The guardian's temple I haven't heard that name in a while. Well, I can tell you everything I do know
A long time ago. My father was the priest at in that temple. He used to tell me all kinds of strange stories
This is odd since I ended up a bar owner
Have to take care of some something would you mind waiting a little bit?
Not at all. Oh just order something for while we wait
Good idea. Tell you what this meal is on the house. It's been a while since I've talked about my father or the temple
All right. All right. What's the most expensive dish on the menu? Is it kidding?
And knows what's up
Anyways as for days, maybe it starts with uh, you know, maybe maybe it's about learning at a school
At some days
Well, now take a look at the list
Oh
There's my
Right, it doesn't show me what I ordered because it's like sensitive stuff and I have to log into my account
Okay, I can't do that
But I did remember ordering
Days I did remember ordering. Um
I
Love love love love series
and
I remember
Getting a couple other stuff, but yeah
I can't remember all of them. I got them all on. Oh, I also got uh
Because a long time ago I played a really bad like
Pan translation of
Totono
You guys know Totono
I think that's a JP name
So, yeah, uh, I have Totono now
So Totono is
Kanajo and Kanajo no
What
What was the last word again
Hold on also known as
What's the English name you and me and her yeah
Kimi Kimi to Kanajo
Oh
So Kanajo no Koi Koi Koi. Yeah that one
Yeah, that one so Totono for short because it's a pretty long title, right? So they just use the like
Words in between Kimi Kanajo
Koi Koi Koli Koli
Yeah, that one I played that one
Ages ago when it was not a very good translation, I think it was like really shitty machine translation
Was it bad funny or just bad the machine translation was just kind of bad
But kind of I mean a lot bad and then it was really funky as well because it wasn't really a
Genuine rip because when the original game came out it was a game that came on a usb, okay
It came for it on a usb to kind of stop um
Uh like pirating and stuff
So it was extremely hard to uh
It was extremely hard to um
To pirate I think it was the first I remember back in the day
It was the first game just re-abuted on a usb
It was distributed on a usb because it had some kind of encoding on it
So
That it's like old school
so when it first came out it was on a usb and uh people had trouble obviously because of the pirating thing
people had
trouble ripping it
from the
From the usb
So it would it was like kind of lost and in different
It was in like it was like a patchwork to to put it together and it was like really shitty
It was really shitty
So yeah
I
I'm surprised
That uh and the reason why and because it was on like a usb
it was
It was how they managed to do
likes
uh certain things
certain coding things that
Would uh for example you would talk to what's her face you would return if they had a coding in the game
uh in the usb that said
Uh after 10 years 15 years 20 years
Anywhere past 10 years
If you go back to the game the character would address you
Uh
And be like it's been x amount of years, huh?
That kind of thing and kind of like broke the fourth wall, right?
So yeah, uh, I remember when
So ddlc before ddlc I when I saw
Uh ddlc I immediately thought of totono and I was like I think this was inspired by totono
and then totono, uh, obviously got distributed
Uh
More now so totono is super well known
Super well now. I'm pretty sure there are more people
um
More people who know about
Like what happens in totono than I do
Then I do because I remember I was such a big deal
big deal when it came out because uh
nitro plus
didn't
Release a lot of games
right
And so when they revealed this new game it was like people were going insane
People were going insane because they were like oh my gosh a new game and they like
And then
You know, there was the twist in the story. I know about the twit
So people just like bought it right people bought it. So a lot of people
Uh, I don't know if there's like a usb of totono still out there, but uh, they advertised it on like
On like the first time it's like here's a usb
Here's a usb that you use. We don't use uh CDs anymore. We use usb now and it'll be so cool
Of course, it was only in japan. So, uh, I don't really know how the usb worked
But all I know was that it was released on a usb
So I'll be probably my first time actually playing it playing it
And not like some really
Bad version of it and some and sometimes a bad version of it would just be like
Not even gameplay. It would just be like screenshots of the game and then the translated text on the game
So
That's how that's how it was played
That's how dang and rompa used to be fans
Translated to fan the fans translation of dang and rompa was a bunch of fucking screenshots
Yes
And you would play it through the website
How would you do it it was it was like, you know, one of those kind of like pointing like they would have the hyperlinks
you know like
Choices and then you would click this the the hyperlink choice
You would pick the hyperlink choices, but it was just like pictures
Anyways, that's how it used to be played
And
It was uh dang and rompa was considered pretty hard
uh
To to translate
Uh, but I'm pretty sure that fan that fan translation they had
Was a pretty big catalyst of why they wanted it to bring bring it over to a western market
Uh
Those were dark days and they were great in their own ways
Oh, yeah, and sometimes sometimes the websites would have a little uh quick time player and you would click it to hear the bg
And you would pretend like you were playing the games with the music playing in the background
Those are dark days
Sometimes um, you know, you there would be a little play button beside the dialogue and you could hear the dialogue as well
The things we had to do to play the japanese games
I was there do not talk to me about the dark days. I was there
I also did this uh
With uh
A bunch of yallie
A bunch of bl as well
I did this with
um
I did this with dramatically murder togenu no chi
Uh, what else did I fucking do it with?
I
Enzai I think it was uh, it was called enzai
So I would consider those played but like never actually played you get what I mean senpai like you would play it
Because the website was so interactable. It was like playing the game, but you didn't really
Lay it because it wasn't you know, it didn't have the ui
Wait, am I old?
Enzai actually has a picture translation
I saw I didn't buy it though because I was like, I don't know if my audience would like that
Like is it just a me thing?
Ah is whatever
Hey, I'm just like way did no one else experience this I only saw a few senpais in chat talk about how they experienced this
What should we get?
Oh, we will have six orders of a large chow mein
We will have six orders of large chow mein with extra vegetables. Is that okay?
Reminds me of the
Amount of work I had to play suki heimei in fate stay night vn only for to come out years later in the osu
I did that with fate stay night as well
And suki and suki heimei actually I did the same thing
And that's where I learned how much I hate emi and shiki
I
Was like wow I hate these guys so damn fucking much
I did that for fate actually now that I think about
Really see it's not all loss. It's just a memory that needs to be uh slowly
Unlocked for you to be like here's the screen translations
I
Something we want to forget mercy. Is it the same thing as watching?
um anime
And like parts you get the hd version if it was in 32 parts and the really shitty version if it was only in three parts
So
And then sometimes some of the parts would be missing so you're like great. I can't find that part
I
That's how it used to be
but now I'm glad that
We're not we're no longer. Um, what's the word?
A lot of things being translated
We don't really have to find because it will be eventually translated here or or it has a simultaneous release
Where the game will be simultaneously released both the japanese version and the english version at once
That was now we live in a pretty good time now
Ah
Like for example, um, I think dungeon meshi had the translation
Uh and their release on on netflix on netflix at the same time. So it's doing a simultaneous release all over the world
Yeah
Oh
Although I wish I want
It's so I just watch anime on free sites. They're more reliable. I'm not gonna lie to you
I
have
I have um
I want to enjoy crunchy roll and all the sites but crunchy rolls service sucks
It sucks. So it's the funny thing is I do try my best to like watch things on like official, um
On unofficial platforms, but sometimes it's just so bad
It's so bad that I have to ask my friend steve
To sail the seeds for it
My cool friend steve
I
I do really try I really try
till um
To to to watch things legally and get things legally, uh bill
Uh, so like for example, like some of my favorite animes. I have the blu ray version of it or the dvd version of it
Love that one cool friend who somehow has everything. Yeah, that's steve steve has everything
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry. I I'm just like rambling about like the dark old days the dark early days of the early days of the internet
Is this with that because it early oh well, it's early enough
I
Early days of being an anime fan. I was bullied for those days and I worked hard for those days
You know what's actually a pretty good decent site to watch like anime for free on
Uh would be like through legal means of course, uh, I was watching um retro crush
I'm not sure if it's free anymore
Ishoki kuai we love you rambles d
Oh my gosh, the texas feed works
Thank you. He sat to a daijou for the ten dollar staff
Tiff I didn't even have to read that out loud
Ha
It was like colon D
It's supposed to be colon D. It's back. It finally didn't break again. Oh gosh. Hold on. I have some screaming here
Okay, uh, I have
Retro crush and there was another app that I was using
That allowed you to watch uh
Watch anime for free and had like sailor moon on it
I forgot what it was called, but it was free. It was free and like legal of course
Uh, yeah, I think it might have been to be
Yeah, it might have been to be uh to be had like sailor moon moon on it. So I think uh
Those places are really cool
Those uh, those places are really cool because they provide some anime for you for free legally so it gives them a more incentive
incentive for for everyone to uh
Uh for anime to be brought to the free to the free
Which is really interesting because to be and like the free retro crush stuff
Uh
Retro crush stuff all their stuff is the same stuff as prime video. So you could just watch it for free
YouTube also has a jp sub episodes of the og sailing moon to watch for free. Yeah, you can just do it
I love those types of means because then like it brings anime to a wider audience for free
And also kind of illegal so you don't have to get a slap on the wrist or
feel guilt if you have such a thing
Uh, certainly miss
I know what you think six orders is a little much for your group
As long as you finish it six orders of chow mein coming right up. I think I'll have to charge you next time though
Wow, they love chow mein, huh?
The enemy outnumbered us almost two to one. However our troops successfully engaged in blitz tactics and we tackled
the attack the enemy
Tenpai, thank you for the 199 super chat misaka best. I've been sailing the seas for too long
Six orders is a lot between two people that means
I mean three people that means
They had to eat two bowls each
Actually today I was really surprised some pie
Um, I actually ate quite a bit today
Hampton 83. Oh, yeah. Hampton. I forgot hampton is hampton strong enough to eat at all
One by one our men had to stop but they're one by one our men had to stop
But there was still so many of them. It wasn't for one soldier who continued her efforts
Her firepower speed and more tactics were just too much for our enemies
She finished off the last enemies with a vengeance
For the enemy who fell to her violence met a cruel and merciless end
Her ferocity towards the enemy
Even drew shivers down the spines of her own allies
How do you like our real-time war report on the great chow man uprising? It's a crazy battle
Oh, wait, did I miss up some readings?
Oh, well, I didn't even notice sometimes. I just get so into it. Uh-huh
I've never had chow man man before
Wait, wait, we forgot about the reserve armies the fresh young carous and broccoli cadets her guys never had a chance
Okay, you two that's enough
Oh
Everyone in curran abby eats just as much I'm sure some of them eat even more than me
Wait, everyone in curran abby eats just as much. I'm sure some of them eat even more than me
Anyhow being a medium and using crest spells takes a lot out of me and I get hungry
All right, I was talking about food. I I surprisingly ate a lot today
I
Usually mama mama bought, uh, vietnamese subs
by me
She bought by me and I usually don't finish a whole one. I only managed to finish half
But today I managed to finish one hold
Hold one so I was impressed with myself
Ha ha ha ha
One whole one so I was usually usually I just um
Papa papa eats one whole one mama eats one whole one
But
What are we sipping gatorade?
I'm drinking gatorade
I'm drinking gatorade right now g zero not the other one
Zero sugar orange
I
Gamer subs not not yet
But speaking of gamer subs
Did you know that you could use cold mercy for 10% off your order of gamer subs?
Use it as meh as much as you want the more you use it the closer we get as we alert to getting waifu cups and
Maybe in the future our own
Creator flavor
Ha ha ha ha ha
Remember to use 10% off
Wait wait that was the wrong way
Remember to use cold mercy to get 10% off your gamer subs order
Anyways, I haven't gotten my pr package yet
So it looks like I got lean flavor
Uh gamer farts and
Blow blow whole blast. I think those are the three flavors I got
And I also got a waifu cup
Gamer farts, yeah apparently some people say it's uh really good
Although I although I do want to try their other flavors too. I was really interested in
I think it was called quality that one was good
Waifu cup of who uh, it's just their their latest season one
I think the one is uh
The the latest uh
Uh the latest season one would be like this kind of like, uh boxing one
If you check out on gamer gamer subs twitter, you should see the design. It's got like a cute
Cute girl punching the cup and it's like cracking
And I love and I love chow man
Not only does it taste great, but looks yummy too
I really enjoyed meal time at the abbey the other girls and I would just chat and eat it was so different
At the abbey in the castle everyone just regarded me as the royalty not a real person
I was the princess and they were my entourage
Dinners were the worst it was all about being about the fine china and etiquette and being proper and dainty and it was lonely
Haha
Although senpai um my my favorite, uh, it's like a reddish. It was a red red and black. Um gamer
Waifu cup although, um
I secretly really like pastel colors, so
Secretly a whole lot actually really like pastel colors
So I might get like a different shaker bottle and like use and keep the uh waifu cup as like a
A memento instead
Many phase pastel blue pink yellow something else. Uh, I like kind of the minty colors and
Pastel yellows and pink and blues
Honestly, if it's like full moco colors, I love it
Because like I said full moco is my is my oh she
Are my oh she's sorry plural, right?
Secretly
Thank you for the five dollar tip anima junkie one two three you're cute and silly yandere
I like you tip for the cute kohai. Thank you
A secret that does not very much a secret. Yeah, I have uh
two
No, no three oh she's because I kind of consider like full moco as one oh she because I just can I just can't see them as
Like separately like apart from each other because together they're you know full moco, right?
So I consider it three
Three oh she's but if I had to separate them that would be four
Um
That would be so my oh she's would be nata re sanna
Because sanna was the first person who I watched and
And I really um
I
Really I really love nata re sanna because
Sanna is basically when I first saw sanna
I was like maybe I could do this too and she really inspired me to try to get into v tubing
And then I learned a lot of Japanese from her
Like suman
Oh
And
And then another vtuber who's like my oh she is
um
Is
Hattoba Hattoba sugu
Is Hattoba sugu
Because I don't know I thought
I was like super admiring sugu because she was so I don't know she just reminded me of like
Japanese cinema like tokyo story and stuff. So I was like oh my gosh. I love I love sugu
She's so quiet and mysterious, you know
The
People the people of adai loves to see lia the princess, but no one knows anything beyond that
What kind of food I like or anything?
And more than ever I need to be the princess and recover the teardrop. Sometimes I miss my days at the abbey
I think my roommate has a nata re sanna figure. I have a nata re sanna figure right here. Oh, I'm touching it
I
I'm touching it. I also have the nendoroid
uh
of
Hattoba sugu as well
But I tried to put sugu on my desk
And sugu's hat kept on falling because there was no magnets in it. There was no magnets in um
In
In sugu's hat
So I had to put her in a cabinet instead like one of my figure cabinets
Because otherwise I kept on knocking her over and I felt really bad
But sanna doesn't really knock over she has a huge base
So she doesn't knock over like at all
But you know what
Okay, I have some free time now. Are you ready to hear about the temple?
Oh, I'm sorry. Are you guys in the middle of something?
Ah
Ah a raid from rena
Nina Nina Nina Nina Nina capitalism raid
Capitalism
Capitalism welcome raiders. Welcome to the stream, but also capitalism
Hi, hi, mercy cutie. Muah. Muah. Hello rena cutie. Muah. Muah
Welcome raiders welcome to stream. I hope you had a great time at rena's
As
At rena's stream you were playing risks risks here. Oh, right. It's
It's where you own a shop. I remember trying to play that and being like I can't be a capitalist scum
Ellie's not yet
Oh
Well, welcome. Hello everyone. My name is mercy modeste
from
violors
gen one and dodge today. We are playing
the
We're playing wild arms altercode f on ps2 with a physical copy. Yay
This is considered a rather rare game
This is considered a rather rare game as I believe the only way you can play it
Is through a physical copy of the game
It is a 3d remake of the original wild arms, which I do not have
So I hope you all enjoy a little playthrough of a little bit of a game. That's uh a little bit of a game
How am I saying a game that's a little bit hard to find
We cannot talk about the e-word here
I cannot talk about the e-word here
I
Can't talk about the e-word and no, I'm not playing playing
I'm not playing it on an emulator. No, I'm not playing on an emulator. I am playing a
with a ps4 run through a retro tink and yeah
Well, this is hard to set up a little bit, but then uh now that I have
Wait ps4
I know I said ps2. I mean I said ps4, but I meant ps2. I'm sorry numbers are hard
Oh
My gosh numbers are hard, okay, uh
On the ps2
I just have my ps4 on the mind because I guess on my mind. I'm just like I have to bring it down
Uh, it's run through the retro tink. It wasn't too hard to set up
Uh, I had to watch some videos low to to set it up, but eventually I got it. I got it and then now that it's um
Um
Now that it's set up
All I have to do if I want to play a different game is like to switch the hdmi
card uh that's attached to my to my game capture
in order to like play my
My
Other consoles like my switch
Like my switch. So it's just it's a pretty easy setup
It's just requires crawling under the desk and like moving moving the uh cables around but that's about it
Oh, that's sweet super easy for future ps4 games. I meant ps2
I meant ps2 ps4. I can just naturally just attach it to the uh
To the uh
Game capture, and it will naturally do it because it it doesn't have like
The what what do you call it output? Yeah, so it'll be fine to just do it
I mean fine to just do it, but it would be uh, but I can play like uh using this setup I can play
um
Gamecube
We
Pretty much anything else
That you can think of
Um, maybe I think the only thing I can't play
Is an xbox. I don't think the x I don't think I have uh, it has the output for the xbox
The xbox 360 I don't think I can do that
So I have to find a different way to play x is an xbox 360 or the original xbox
I can't remember. Do you have all those consoles too? I do. I do have a lot of uh consoles
That I hopefully work. I remember on the day. No, not the day like the week of
No, the day of it was actually the day of I think um
I had my ps2 and I broke it wouldn't turn on
And then I had to run out so I'm using a borrowed ps2 right now
I was crying a little bit so after this game
I'll probably have to have to give this ps2 back or I I beg I beg to like buy it
I I can beg to buy it off of uh
Off of my friend and be like blaze blaze blaze. Let me have it
Don't break the borrowed ancient device now. I'll try not to but it feels like it's funny
It's funny
They loaned me
Two ps2s and only one of the two ps2s only one of them worked
So I got and so there's two broken ps2s right over there
Oh
And I'm like why does everyone have a broken ps2
Is it a ps2 slim no although if one was at a good price I would probably get myself a slim it just runs better
I have
What they call a fat boy
Oh
That's why you thought you had a ps4 two plus two
There's no me to me. I love you, but you're so mean to me
I love how my friends all like
Roast me really well
I'm like a pig spit roast
Over a flame
And rena's just slowly turning
I
Do love me
It's really funny because um, I think I'm just
What's the word I'm someone who's really easy to bully
I'm someone who's really easy to bully
What
And I'm really easy to bully I guess it's because I'm clumsy
where I get caught off
Caught by surprise by a lot of things especially by my gen mates. They'll say stuff and I'm like
Or like Azra Azra always tries to eat me literally
She always tries to eat me she's always like
Yeah, I can't I can't do her voice, but I'll try
mercy
you're so
delectable
And juicy and I'm like
Oh
You give up the vibe people wanting to bully you but they do it to get a cure reaction. That's exactly it, isn't it?
I always get like headpats and stuff
Especially from the girls because they're like, oh mercy, it's okay
It's mercy. It's okay mercy. You'll be fine. And then I'm just like
You know just kind of in a state of shock
Don't worry about it if you would we would like to hear about the guardians temple sure thing
First
The guardians temple is north of malama right past the lake that passed the woods
Okay, let me see what else. Okay. You probably don't know this part, but since it's not really part of the legend
My father told me about a prayer room which only priests are allowed to enter
Used to tell me that or that about that room a lot. Maybe you wanted me to fall in this footsteps
Anyways, here's the juicy part
I can't escape from the word juicy. I just said it. I just said it about about azra. Is this game reading my mind?
Oh
You want to listen up
At 3 30 the door to that prayer room opens
Pretty sure that's what he used to tell me. Is this what you guys want to know?
It's exactly what we're looking for
That's great. I'm glad I can be some help to you. Why don't you stay here tonight? Don't worry. I won't charge you for it
I
Can't get copyright
Okay, now we're good, right
I hope it's not based off of the system's time. I sure hope not
I sure hope not
Oh gosh, is it somebody look that up
So
There's the temple
Were you hit by copyright last game? Yeah, because I didn't uh play over it
Hold on
I forgot I forgot the most important thing senpai. I forgot to save
I
Need to go back to town and save
I uh
I
I'm
It's something tied to the temple. Okay, good because I would be like, uh, I definitely do not want to
toe
mess with the system time because that's kind of annoying
I
Need to remember what game did that there was a game that I remember that does that do you senpai?
Do you know any games that do that?
Walk need to save we save at this bird
Hello, would you like to save your progress?
Yeah, I want to save my braggers
Yeah, tons of stuff in pokemon. Yeah, yeah
Animal crossing game cube and some pokemon games. I think it was like specifically like certain pokemons will appear at certain times
In metal gear solid three one boss would die of old age if you waited a week
Wait, what is this? It's so cute. Wow. Look at that. It's so cute. Look at the spooky apple
Girl apple
I'm scared is wearing a robe
Oh
Goodbye apple
Goodbye you apple
Let me in let me in let me in
This is a lot of temple
Right handle operates the long hand
Let's handle operates the shorthand
point out the right spot not the
Wrong angle. What's that mean?
Hold on
Yeah
Oh
Wait what
This is 330 right
Oh, right move it a little bit past there we go. Thank you. I forgot
Like a real clock
Woohoo
Oh
Fit
Battle please it
Sam pies
Would you I know you would I know you would oh shit
Oh
Only go hide better not be cool. Oh shit. Hold on. I ran out of batteries on my
On my pad
I bet the scarecrow is weak to fire it has to be right
Oh
Wait they died already
Scarecrow looks like a harvester. Oh remember when that I broke that game. That was good time
Oh
Oh, I was hoping you died one hit actually
Reflex reflex magic understood and that case just hit it hit
Thank you
It's not even a week to fire. I know right
You mean my stuff I got a breath mint you want to breath mint
Sam pie
Oops
These are doors
That light looks flows the true path
Then the deceiving illusion will disappear and the door to the altar will be opened
Light
Use the fire on on the the Griffin thing
I feel like breath mints are like gum like
You know like once you open a pack everyone's like can I have a gum?
Can I have a gum? Can I have a mint? Can I have a gum? Can I have a gum?
Ah
Can I pick one up?
That's blue and that's blue
Ah sometimes sometimes I like
When I was a fucking I was a kid
I was a kid
Like I would open a bag of chips and like all these could become running going can I have a piece can I have a piece?
So I like crushed it
I crushed into small
small pieces
and gave it to them and
And then I was like you flock to me like birds and you won't eat like birds
Imagine
Like a little fucking brat just says shit to you like this
I
Can't believe I would
I would like say shit like that
Oh, this is where the amnesia came from
Oh, thank goodness it's missed
But it's it's gone like I love a lot
Oh, it's wiggling
You
I know it's wiggling but I'm a little confused
No magic
Okay, they both reflect they both will reflect magic so we can only do physical
Physical
It just has a kick it just kicks you
In a hole
I can't believe it just kicks
Can I just pick up the light
I
What's this puzzle?
Well, it says one the deceiver will will go away, right?
Well, I have to do all physical moves
I
Has to be physical moves, right?
The light when I they said light
I expected this see and you can't walk through them
Oh
Do you I just moved through it
Do I seriously just moved through ah
Thank you for remembering for one month. I just realized this is happy one month. Happy one month
Can ambush
I can't believe you just use a scanner and walk. That's so rude
I
It's like haha the light and I'm like
Really really you're gonna be like this game
Oh wait, I saw birthday
Oh, thank you, Ray kuma for gifting five
That's like the light of a scanner
Oh
What do these gems do you have some earth gems as well, I don't know
But I'm gonna save it
Somebody's birthday hold on
Oh
There you go
I
Hate I hate it when they have more than one or two two boss not two bosses two monsters. Sorry. It's so annoying
Think I did that one pretty well. I think I I played happy birthday on the automaton pretty well
Is there is there
There more
All further right, there's a
There's the third door. Oh, yeah, hold on
There was a third door and I was I forgot about it because I'm just super forgetful
Literally gets nothing
Why does it have to have titties and no arms, what does this mean this does this make does this make this Lamia like a nugget
Oh what nugget
Never heard of a nugget before
Oh, well just to let you know a nugget is someone who has no arms and no legs
There's two doors
I
Oh
I don't know. I think I was taught by
by
the vila
the vila girls
That uh the fetish is called is called a nugget
Wait fetish, yeah
Oh
Kind of nugget I was taught
Yeah more money for guns
There's another one over there
I
I'm getting real tired all of the actually the run random encounter is kind of annoying, you know
You
What's the button to cancel them again see I don't want to use the button unless it's like a thing a time thing
Or I need to to really do it
Does that make sense
Because like you only get a limited amount of it
I
Remember what game was so impossible to play
Because of the stupid random encounter it was just like every step you take it was another encounter another encounter another encounter now
I was just like
You
I'm getting a lot of stuff after f1
Oh
It's a lot of jrbg there was one that was very
Particularly like annoying. I think I tried like wild arms too. I don't remember which one it was
I think it was one of the wild arms. I opened it and the wild
The like encounters just kept just kept happening and happening and I got so old mad
Like I kind of like Mario because the encounters don't
They're not really random you can't avoid them, you know
I found it
I
Have gone back
Shooter dark shooter dark shooter dark how'd I say this again?
It's telling us something
Those who wish for guardians power to receive your power you must challenge your test
Now it's test time. It's rather old-fashioned. Oh well
Sure earth guardian grudive his body is strong as solid to deflect bullets and magic
Earth guardian
Who will challenge the grudive trial that would be jack, right?
Because
Bullets don't don't work and magic don't work. So jack will have to slice through
Next is fire guardian more
galt
It waves wings or terrible fire is difficult to stop the roaring blaze
Fire guardian who will challenge morse galt's trial?
Um
Rudy
Lastly wind guardian fen gallon runs his claws are sharp and fast a strong wind that nobody can catch
Oh shit, maybe maybe it should have been the other way
They're passing this point. There's no way back turning back. Are you ready?
Uh reconsider the combination. Thanks
Can magic miss though magic misses all the time
But if it's as fast as wind a bullet is as fast as a wind, right?
Jack
Celia
Rudy
Yeah, so Rudy can shoot things really fast hexa Celia even has fire her main thing is fire, right?
Yeah, let's fucking do it
All cracks in the plane if pressure is applied it may break
Oops almost again
Uh
Does it start? Yeah
Yeah
Oh
Shit
It's timed
Oh
Did I fuck up
Did I run it
No nothing happens when I'm running
Okay, maybe I should run hold on
Fuck
Yes, we're good. We got it
I'm glad that it wasn't very picky on where the bomb for being placed
Oh shit
Oh shit, I have to literally run give me a second
Hang out
Oh
Fuck
I'm too slow
Okay, let's do this from another angle
Oh
Come on
I'm too slow for this
This is hard when I don't know this is really hard when those turns are really sharp
Fuck like that
Fuck
Are you serious that one didn't go off
Easier like this oh wristy hurts now
Oh
My gosh how close does it have to fucking be?
Hey, what about
Fuck it why am I even like this
It won't fucking do it
Why why why are you like this?
Oh
Thank goodness
Small one you wish for the guardians power a power too great for human hands a dangerous power
Just because you desire the power doesn't mean you deserve it. You must show me that you can handle it
Oh, you're so cute die
Oh
Small one who wishes for guardians power
I accept that you have the ability to receive the power of wind in your small body
But you control the power when you must have strength of heart
Small one who wishes for guardians power show your heart
Show your strength by overcoming my test
Did I get it oh
Yippee
Oh
Once these attack everyone
Literally first reaction shoot
You your power is different from ours as if a monster I'm scared
Oh wait, it's Tony from the town right hold on you yep
Oh
This world needs not your existence there is no place for you in this world
You're a stranger in this world who is not accepted by anyone. Why do you continue fighting?
Why do you use your powers you think it helps others?
The more you use your power the more people run from you
The power of arm power of destruction is the power that monsters possess
Look at yourself your appearance you're plainly different from us
This is our world this is not a place for you
It's the blue hair I swear it's the blue hair
Okay
I'm fine
I
Cannot control this thing. Oh wait, it just opens. Okay, never mind. I don't have to run
I don't have to run I thought I had to run
Oops
I can take my sweet time
What is this
Oh
Oops
Okay
Oh wait, hold on
This one looks shorter
This one looks shorter I didn't notice it was shorter
There we go, and then we send ham pond
I think I can get ham pond
Maybe
Wait
I'm buttons stay pressed
Oh, they don't need to be pressed at the same time, okay
It's easier because ham pond can jump over gaps
Oh, I just have to be on this side
Oh
I think
No
Maybe has to be together
The gap too big
I
Maybe like that
Yeah
I
Thought I had to do it at the same time so I started going things small and you wish for the guardian's power
Power too great for human hands a dangerous power
Just because you desire the power doesn't mean you deserve it much first show me that you can handle it
Oh jack was way easier than rooties
Oh
That would not do much at all
Small one that wishes for guardians power
I accept that you have the ability to receive earth power in your small body
but
To control my earthly powers. You must have strength of heart
Small one who wishes for guardians power show your heart
Show your strength by overcoming my test
May I level up
No
Nifty big stomp
Oh my gosh, he has to is so loud right now
What a tuney looking ass sword
This is great workout as long as I have this power
I'll never have to run from anyone this magic sword. I will cut away my disgusting past
This is absolute power
Wow
I'm blind
Oh
Who is it stop hiding and show yourself
No, it can't be he is the guy from the beginning
You are a man who ran away
A man without courage a man who hopes for power a man addicted to power
I never withdrew myself. My heart was never broken in battle
But you ran away deserted your unit and ran away
Ran from your responsibility
And from yourself didn't you run away?
What what are you saying?
You're not running away then can you say it can you tell us your name?
Yes, what you're doing is just a self justification. Why don't you see the truth?
You still use the sword for destruction, but you cannot use the sword to protect what you hold dear
I
Know I know that but I'm trying to
I need power for revenge
Wait until absolute unit. I'm ain't absolute power. Please wait. Just wait wait
Do I have to be left alone again? I am I am
Hahaha absolute unit. Oops. I'm an absolute power
Corrupts absolutely
Please do not make me fall again. I will cry
I will cry I will cry
I
Need I need okay, hold on. I might need a different angle. This is too hard for me
You
Excuse me
Fuck
Oh
Come on
Why did jack have the easiest one what the hell?
Oh
Why is hers is always the hardest
Thank fucking god
Small one you wish for the guardians power a power too great for human hands a dangerous power
Just because you desire the power doesn't mean you deserve it. You must first show me that you can handle it
I
That's a big ass dragon
Big fire
I don't think that's gonna do much
I
Why did you heal you lost nothing?
Small one who wishes for guardians power
Except that you have the ability to receive the power of fire in your small body
But control my fire. You must have strength of heart
Small one who wishes for guardians power show your heart
Show your strength by overcoming my test
Okay, that was so easy
I just zapped it once
I think you have to show like two moves or like three moves and it's like, okay, you're done
I she not in a little creepy place
It's impossible this castle. Why am I at aldehyde castle?
A princess goes on a journey to save the world you must much obliged
But you are the prince of the princess of aldehyde nothing more you must fulfill your duty
I know I understand that it's my choice. I'm
Nobody in this castle calls your name. You are not wanted
Huh, I will not accept such a thing. I do not want to think that
You know that is the truth
You are not loved by anyone. Why are you surprised?
What a fucking lie. What a fucking lie. Everyone's like, oh the princess. We love you princess
But you are me. I am thou and thou art I
I
Or I like my favorite, who are you? Who are you? I'm you what's stronger
You went off in a dangerous journey why for love to fulfill your duty as a princess why
The truth is you just wanted someone to worry someone to confirm you were loved
You let for danger you cut your hair in front of everyone everything was selfish
You sing for peace in the middle of a broken city in hopes of receiving someone's love
You
Are a terrible
I think she's a pretty good princess
I'm sorry. I thought she was pretty good. I mean it was all jack's fault anyway in that balloon
Brain worms hit brain worms be hitting different
You know, I feel like she's been a pretty decent princess. Yeah
My thoughts and my behavior, are they wrong? Are they not pure? Please someone tell me
It's impossible because nobody loves you just accept it
You
Like it was like partly jack's fault and then like the balloons
And then we blame everyone who manufactured that balloon afterwards, but like yeah brain worms got hands
Senpai you are loved by me
Aggressive
You must realize you do not have the ability to love anyone don't look to me for empathy
We uh appreciate some aggression in our love you do
Sturder dark shaman and her warriors why are your hearts so weak
These guys were like wow you guys are fucking bussies. What the fuck
Cowards weaklings. Do you love me enough to put me in a hydraulic press three?
Thank you. He's after died you for the 10. Um
I don't want you to put in you in the hydraulic press
But
You know
If that's what true love is and that's what you really want I'll do it
for love
What about a different kind of press you want me
To any of us you if that's what you really want
Then I will oblige
The test of guardians wait the test of guardians assigned us did we not pass
Decay of the world means decay in people's hearts
It makes us wonder
Is it wise for us to place our power in the world's fate under your charge?
They say such selfish things I showed my power to the guardians why are they not satisfied with it?
But we are the powerless existence we lost most of our power to hold this world the heart is too weak
The guardians voice
It reached my heart, but this this is not only their voice
heart
The guardians heart is felt in my heart along with their voice
Their hearts anger sorrow disappointment and resignation
These are what fills my heart
I'm sick of listening to this nonsense
Except the strength of my sword or I will make you up except it gosh so aggressive
Jack I know I have like a little aggressiveness, but this is like you know another another level
It's like oh you're gonna beat up these stained glasses. Oh look at these stained glasses. They're so pretty and sparkly
Oh
This man is too fucking to me
Your false bravado your rowing anger they are the evidence of your weak heart
Your hearts are so weak with such weak hearts you cannot confront the threat now
But we do not have power or a way to confront the threat either the guy I must accept his fate
Wait a minute. You can't just judge the strength of our hearts
I can
You're a little
Bitch baby. You're always gonna be a little bitch, baby. Hello
Hello, bitch baby cry baby snot nose little bitch
It was enough to see that humans do not have the power to fight with monsters
Don't do my man dirty like that. It was 10% his fault
That's that's me real
Without fighting power
How can you hope to save a gaya? How can you take the teardrop back?
Teardrop, how did you know?
You do not need to tell us we guardians. No we can feel it
He doesn't need the toxic kohai experience everyone needs the toxic kohai experience
I am the true guardian here
The brilliance of the teardrop is in a sense the heart of this of this star so it connects the life and the star
Oh
We need it. Well, just senpai you want me to insult you?
Um
Yeah, no, okay
Only mildly pleased because I was like I can go pretty hard but that might be bad
Negative affirmation ASMR I don't think I would do that because
Frankly to say it I feel like a lot of people have like extreme brain worms
like
To the point where it's so unhealthy that I feel like
You know
I feel like um
If I perpetuate that it can get to like dangerous levels does that make sense
Which is why I don't want to do that
Which is why I'm telling
Is why I'm telling my senpais like things like let's go volunteering let's make the world a better place
Because doing stuff sometimes doing stuff for others makes the brain worms go away
Hey
A teardrop is the very essence the life of the star now life with Ogaea
I mean the monsters will use teardrop to put an end to life on the star that is correct
They intend to revive a great demon named mother
mothers
mother
Excuse me mother. You're in the wrong game
This is the wrong game
By using the life the teardrop releases
It will mark the beginning of monsters and say no the end of this world
Mother the name of their boss
Chamin even though your heart is weak you must ask do you wish for guardians power?
I am a human with a weak heart. I know this. I always have and for this reason
I wish to go to grow strong
Guardians power that rules this world. I
I wish for the power
You made a fool of us shut the fuck up
Shut the fuck up jack
People are talking right now. It's not your turn
I can at least be mean to jack because jack's not real
Ah
You wish for power because of your weak heart
Let's not waste any time since mother's resurrection is approaching fast. Chamin. We will place our power with you
Before mother awakes before monsters unify their power and hearts into one
We will transfer you to the monsters castle within earth with our remaining power
Was that possible?
We can because we are guardians
Follow the brilliant teardrop and fly to the land covered with snow and terror
Senpai's name jack. They're fine
Senpai's name jack. I love you
But this this jack, uh
Nah
When you get your sight back you'll be in the monsters castle
Chamin you must transform our power
incarnate the heart to power
We guardians will become your power to destroy the steel menace
With our last remaining ability
Take the teardrop back from the demon's hand
Is the only
Wait taking the teardrop back from the demon's hand is the only hope of saving this world's future
This is the guardians temple. We didn't reach the monsters castle, but why?
This impact is pain
You shall never forget
the stroke of zek fraz zek freeds
dark spear
With our remaining power
It's not possible to transfer you to the monsters castle
You're away anyway. Can't we do anything about it?
When hope collapsed the future did our power collapsed and now it's a miracle to destroy monsters
Ah again
Indeed a miracle if it is soul
We should place our last hope in this in these humans
Chamin and warriors
We four guardians will try once more by unifying our mere remaining power
The destination is a sealed land
Island where mother is held
The wicked place where the demons will resurrect mother
A dire fate awaits if not stopped
The teardrop is the brilliance of life
Is is the
Desecration it is a desecration to use it for mother's resurrection
I had to I had to win for that
Where the fuck are we?
Guardians damn them they not only spy on us but transfer humans to our castle
They're transfer
You pierce their powers with your terrible dark spear
Okay, you're kind of hot
And cute wait
You're the you're the girl you're the girl from the beginning. You're the the lady of the sword
You're the lady sword. Yeah, lady sword person. Yeah the intro law person
Looks like she's a bad guy now
Even though the human guardians finally claim in contact what are you going to do?
Those who forget those no, what was the voice I did those who forget how to fight can only leave them to their
destruction
What do you think of bugaya the world of decay and waste a land of weaklings who dare not fight?
Humans elu
and guardians
Are there any who would stand up to us would dare to confront us?
No, the answer is definitely no humans cannot do anything the guardians do not frighten us either
Oh
There's all hazad here you are absolutely right
However, there's another worrisome resistance power the elu
There
Their existence is being researched
Anyways look there
Here oopsies the big game
We met this guy he was killing everyone in the intro
They might have been destroyed in the past thousand years you could not confirm their existence
Although there are some evidence mostly broken junk buried under soil
Once I stand wait once I stand the frontline of this war there is no chance of winning for them
It's funny to see the weak running their screens make me laugh
Ha ha ha
But I long for a worthy opponent attack of how to hide it was too easy
A truly strong fighter could have taken the teardrop without all that needless wanton destruction
What what are you saying? How dare you say such a thing to me?
Oh
Yeah, it totally looks like a job or next to everyone else, huh? This is a battlefield
What the strong does is justice you should be punished for your mouth
Stop it berserk you two harken
Let us
Prosper us have proper silence while we await mother's awakening. Yes the calm before the storm
Here are the gathered are here those are gathered are four nights the dream we have is one
Have mother awaken as our glorious leader once again
The guardians disgusting seals
Here three of them who would release the first seal?
The honor
The honor will be mine. I will step up. I shall have the utmost honor in breaking the first seal
Don't make those humans who can contact the guardians my target. Don't meddle with this anyone
I don't remember what voice I did
Not gonna lie to you. I kind of wanted to do chatterbox's voice, but I can't do chatterbox's voice
Well, well my amusement will be stolen by him a mighty berserk is in high spirits. Yeah, my god
What I want is not honor nor cheap satisfaction
It's something I do not have a battle for life and death
When mother awakens all who live in bogeye will sleep and never rise
When the time comes we knights will stand as rulers of this world
We shall be one
Ah
My fucking eyes
Oh, it's harkens true identity already spoiled we kind of figured that harkin is already like the girl from the intro
What was it the the lady of the sword or something
Wait like Nikkei chatterbox. Yeah, I mean he kind of looks like chatterbox, but more like fish chatterbox
Ouch, where am I?
A sealed place the guardians told us they would try to transport us there
And at the sealed place we must stop mother's revival. That's all they said
It's okay to fight against evil, but being bossed around by the guardians is how on how to protect the world. I don't like that
Obtained hero
Obtained medium fiery wage obtained medium gale claw
This medium thank you rude if you more galt and gallon
Thank you for giving me your powers
And to the northwest is a hidden town it is called basker village
The basket is our world protectors
Listen to their advice and stop the demons mother's revival
Aha, that's nice and all but uh
That was a plot twist completely spoiled. Oops
Yes
You again
Run away you coward
I love guns so much gun is so good
On par with gob, huh?
Gun is so good
You
Wait what happened to my hp holy shit wait, when did I lose so much hp?
Is it basker village
What's that bit thing it's like the autohill gauge
Okay, first off I want to say
All right warriors of the sand
I mean welcome. I mean I mean I mean
I mean it's so cute. I love I mean a lot
Oh my gosh, welcome to the stream
How stream great we're doing so great. I think are you guys having fun?
Oh my gosh, it's maryl too. Maryl is so cute and I love her
He's so adorable and it's so
sweet
Yeah
Oh
Welcome to the stream everyone
Welcome to the stream
I think everyone knows me already
I introduce myself anyway
Yee-haw howdy y'all my name is mercy modis from real origin ones
And all
Ah
Today we are playing wild arms altacode f on the ps2
With the physical copy yeah, hey oldy partner
All of like the southern
Seven pies are like I hate mercy modis. Why does she always do a shit accent?
Well welcome welcome we're playing a pretty rare, uh
We're playing a pretty rare game
uh
I
Don't think it's a game that you can easily find and there's no like digital copy of it. I believe
So it's a pretty rare game and I have a physical copy. Yeah
It's a remake of the first wild arms
But it's uh
It's like a 3d remake
Yeah
And it was released in uh
2005 to the north american market. I think
Oh, well, but yeah, it's a pretty rare game a little bit hard to find so i'm glad that I can play it
With everyone
Nah
Oh
The us game or a japanese game it a japanese game
But like, you know, yeah
But like, you know, it didn't yeah, this is the us release or north american release
Look I can open open the little disc thing and it comes with the bonus anime dvd
It contains episode one of the wild arms anime series
Yeah
The anime good from what I heard no
No, I heard the the anime was not good
But yeah, it's a bit of a rare game and I'm happy to have it
I already saved I'm gonna do it again. I don't trust myself
Sometimes I feel like some anime adaptations are pretty good and some are not that good
But there is an anime adaptation. I really like uh, so, you know, devil may cry or they may not cry. I don't know
Um that anime is bad, but I really like it
I don't know. I just enjoy
Uh
I enjoy that what's his face really loves strawberry sundaes and I feel like that should be a that's just like really great
Yeah Dante yeah Dante eating uh
eating tons of
of strawberry sundaes
And pizza doesn't eat pizza in the games. I don't think he has strawberry sundaes
Yeah in the game he likes pizza, but I don't think it ever
showed that he had like
a strawberry sundae obsession
And then I like the little girl that like takes along with him in the anime too. I don't know it's just
Oh
That's always like fun for me
Patty yeah
The only thing I remember from the anime is him ordering a strawberry sundae in a bar. Yeah, and then the the bar
Pender is like
Only makes only keeps like the ingredients for strawberry sundaes there for him
I don't know. I thought that was cute. I was like, oh
Ordering strawberry sundaes in a bar. I want a strawberry sundae now
He's canon character in the games too funny enough really I thought it was good
It's like the butterfly pt for kohai. Yeah, it's so good
the the single drink that uh
It's summer though. It's summer. I went to another store
Uh the same brand of boba and they were like they had they had that drink again
And I was like it's a summer drink. It's back and better than ever and I want to sip. I want to sip it
I want bubble tea
I want bubble tea down
I want bubble tea again now I'm now I know I have cravings
Now I have cravings again
It's so late now
The all if if I have that craving like maybe like a few hours earlier
The place that I I really like opens until like 10 10 p.m
You know what if I ever
If I would I would probably recreate that that drink that I really enjoy as like a gamer subs drink
But I don't know if like
It'll be good because I like it for its coconut or it's like boba boba tea
flavor for its milk tea flavor, you know
Mercy's snippets like snippets
I don't know. I don't know maybe I think it's it's harder to get drinks than it is to get a waifu cup
Okay, during the sunrise the site of the sun hitting Mount Zennum is nothing short of spectacular
If you happen to stay here overnight, please do yourself a favorite and wake up early to catch the view of the mountain
Welcome feel free to examine anything that might interest you
Paws a pinwheel
What does it do?
Cures, ping, peppy corn
Peppie corn
My hammer, holy shit. These are expensive
Another migrant seal, huh?
Have a safe journey
I want to go here let me in no it's not letting me in
Wow
What brings you here today? Oh, would you like to do?
Oh, you're you're the magic person here. I haven't gotten another crest graph in a long time. What the hell?
Please come back anytime
Over there is the order of wind
The legend has it that Zephyr's
Zephyr's chosen one shall stand on the altar and awaken the western wind of hope
Gary and the same lady you're the same lady
Did we miss the graph I'll have to go back to that area then
Oh
Woo-gah
I don't read the sky reaching demon tower. Yeah, I want to read it
Having no wings did not stop the aloo from reaching the sky
The aloo's extraordinary alchemy skills enabled them to build a sky reaching tower
The teleportation device was installed on top of the tower
It was said to be a ladder to the sea of stars
At the end of the great war all aloo and humans were exhausted many projects like the massive tower
The tower fell into disrepair and the entrance was sealed by the guardians
But we'll never know the reason why the aloo built this tower to the stars
Wanderers of a strange land you need rest your
Wings from a long journey feel free to stay with us
Allow me to guide you to the sleeping area and your restful night be blessed by the guardian
Oh, we get it for free. Please don't take my money
You're not gonna get me
I
Am
I am the chief of this village. I've been around for so long. I have forgotten my name
Call me whatever you'd you like Rudy jack and shrine maiden Cecilia
How do you know all of our names
How would I not had a dream about you visiting us here in basker village
I also dreamt
about the guardians and the demons
Of course, so is nothing more than a dream, but I believe a dream is one that makes is what one makes of it
This dream was just too vivid to ignore
Guardians warriors, you must listen carefully
Deep in the mountains in Mount Zenim lies a keystone a mother who the monster seek is sealed within it
Destroying the seals that contain her would be their priority
Should the demons wish to awaken the mother
The mother
Shrine maiden and her warriors Mount Zenim is located to the northeast of our village
I firmly believe you are the ones who can summon the Zephyr
Zephyr grant us the western wind of hope
Visit the keeper of the altar of wind who will be of great help to you
I
Hope I can dodge copyright. I just don't want to share I don't want to share my hard work
You will live and die on Fogaya. You're the children of our mother planet
Upsies
And Zephyr or Zephyr
I say like Zephyr, uh-huh
Oh, is this a guy who does the thing there are fragmented gems that hold the power of the elements like earth, wind, fire, and water
Find these amid the ruins bits of their power of the guardians that leaked from the ley line and crystallized
Well, I have some
Oops didn't mean to uh, to totally, you know
Just draw your house
Thanks for the stuff
They found something
Here
Tengela
Oh my gosh
Ah
Oops I hope these resets
Oh another house
Can I walk in that house with with my thing
Oh, yeah, maybe I can use handpan
Give me your stuff
I will set your barn on fire
Yeah
Can I get to that small little crate over there?
Do we just talk to the chicken then
So
Goodbye chickens
Maybe vomit
Maybe
Who books feet of the Baskers, let's go
The Quran region and Baskers both worship the same guardians
Baskers both worship the same guardians. However, the abbey believes in living with nature
Baskers believe believe in living in nature
Centro to this belief is the concept of regression the return to an existence within nature
A natural way of life where human lived as part of the ecosystem rather than a part
It was believed in practice amongst the Basker
The science of the environment is unknown to have been taught by the elu long ago
Possibly directly related to the ancient Basker
Elu were known for their intimate knowledge of the laws of nature
They understood the magic of elements
The elu incorporated this knowledge to create their stunning technology
While the Baskers applied it to their way of life
Wait
I'm just gonna accept I'm not gonna get it it it mocks me
It mocks me unless there's something in there that I can throw at it
Like a jug or a jar
Nah
Yeah
I want it
Fuck
This is this is
My destiny
I can't go out there it doesn't exist
It doesn't exist
I can't go out there
Oh
This is heck oh or can I oh no, no, I can't
No, no, I can't
Oh well
That's
My berry
My berry with the heck
Fuck
Please let me have it again this time I won't throw it over there
Yeah
That was embarrassing I got too excited
I got too excited and I was like oh look at that how handy I'm gonna throw it at the area
Oh
I'm not but a fool
Can I ever go on these ladders maybe I can hold on
I
Our chief can see the future in his dreams
That does not mean he can foresee everything about the future
There's no absolute future since a strong will can change one's fate
I'm sorry, but I need to bomb this
I
What if I like trying to send excuse me trying to send here. Yeah, it works
You
You know the original you could bomb the chickens in the first village and then some would turn into items really
Wait, let me talk let me talk let me talk
Generation after generation believed in the revival of the guardians in this frontier
Our chief dreamt of the western wind
I sense a change on the horizon feel the anticipation building up in this village
Yes, stop give me it
Yeah
You have a bookshelf you got any cool books and shelves
No, no thanks anyways
You
Got it
We got it I gotta I gotta loot this entire place first, you know
I seriously don't know how to get there
I
It's a little havoc as a treat
Man
Maybe we'll get into all that will help later. Yeah, I tried handpan already didn't work
Okay, let's go here you're right
Everyone steps into the altar and looks to up to the sky a sandy wind blows nothing happens
I'm afraid Zephyr the western wind of your hope is not ready to respond to your call
Perhaps the power lost by the guardians is making this progress more difficult
Understand that there are many abandoned guardian temples throughout Fogaya
There are ruins that honor time known as the perpetual engine located northeast of our village
These warrior and shrine maiden I ask you to gather up all of the guardians power
Only then will the Zephyr respond to your call
Render the wind of hope
We
Well
We're off the sea
We're off the sea people
On another side mission, but I think
Should we do another temple senpai or should we save that for another day?
I can probably push myself to do another temple probably
How you feeling my eyes are a little dry and I have to wake up early tomorrow
Well, at least we have this little map in the corner now
That's not as brutal and evil
More goat y'all got no, um gonna just go swimming it's gonna go swimming at a lake
Yeah, well, I think I'm gonna arrest it for today
Oh
Yeah, let's rest for today. That was a good run. I think senpai we did so much
Yeah, we did so much
Oh
Almost dropped my stuff I have too much controllers on my desk like a controller for every game system
Okay, well senpai you made a lot of progress tonight
I put my hat away
Oh, but tomorrow is supposed to be really really hot
So that's why we're gonna go out to the lake stick our little feet sees into the water. Maybe sitting it
It's supposed to be really hot. So I'm hoping that it will cool off because it's just that hot, you know
Let me find
I
Schedule
Tomorrow
I am nothing it's my day off. Whoo. That's why I'm going to the lake just for a little bit
It's probably just gonna be like an hour and then I go back home and do more work
You know like always
You
And then
Thursday is killer seven, but I might change up killer seven
Because I kind of feel like maybe I'm not skilled enough to play killer seven
And I don't remember much of what I did for killer seven. You know what I mean?
You know what I mean right now. I'm just kind of like
Uh
I don't know
I'm simply not skilled enough. I'm simply just bad at games
But who knows uh
If it's
Not going to be killer seven. I might replace it with like a visual novel or something
Because I can
And then
Yeah, maybe a visual novel or something, but it depends on how I feel if I feel like
Yeah, I can totally do killer seven
I'll do killer seven
But sounds like
But I'm I'm getting the feeling that I'm gonna be like I am not skilled enough to do the shooty shoot
And the shooty shoot might be too much for my my we
My lack of uh
Uh, what do you call it? Reflexus
My reflexes are uh weak and could use a lot of work
So for a backup I was thinking I would play
I would play like
Maybe a pointing click or maybe like something super relaxing like a visual novel
When you look up like if I if I
What's the word sort things out visual novel?
You peel is too hard and I am very weak
Let's see I have
Like that like that. Oh, yeah, I have like all of the muvelove wait is muvelove
Yeah, muvelove might not be safe
But I can probably choose something else. Hi. Thank you so much for the super chat
Thank you for the nz nz was nz new zealand
And thank you so much
Thank me please
Oh
There
There there you go
Ha ha ha
Yeah, I have no idea
Honestly, I don't know what I'll play but I'll figure it out
Probably hopefully fingers crossed
Thank you
I forgot I didn't turn off the senpai alerts for this one
Senpai
Thank you
I I need to like fix it on on this on this one specifically
I knew it
Ha ha after that is a be a lord event
It is six hours of continuous
ASMR
From start of the day
To the end of the day starting with icy I believe
And ending with me mercy modiste
Based off of our hours
We're running an ASMR train. That's correct. We're raining. We're running an ASMR train on everyone
My ASMR will just be using you all as guinea pigs for new
And old triggers. I'm gonna be testing them out on you. Hopefully they're not too harsh
Ha ha
So I won't be a themed one
But I hope you will all enjoy it anyway
And for Saturday since the ASMR
Train is running on a on my usual membership day
Uh
Memberships are moving one day
to Saturday
And the theme for the members ASMR is
Cat girl
And that is
Exclusive to members only
Are rather
So
You'll have so if you would like to watch that
That stream it will be at the
Snippet member tier if you are at the snippet member tier that uh stream will be available to you
Whoa, and then it's my day off again and then another week is starting
And then another week is starting and then another week that starts is um
Um
Would be
Yeah, and then after the the new week and then the week after
I'll have a shorter week
But
Senpai I'll be gone on vacation. I'll be gone from the 8th
To the 14th
Oh
You will miss me, right?
You'll miss me, right?
Well, it will be the job of senpais to keep each other accountable
Start whacking and when there are string eyes or any runners
And
And then we'll have uh and then we'll be back and then I'll I'll love to to just hang out with um with everyone
And it'll be lots of fun
And then we're back to fun and then just doing my regular schedule as always
That's all for me other than the regular stuff
Other than the regular stuff is there any more questions
Or concerns or anything that you would like clarification from
No
So I doing all good, yeah
You still love us, of course I do I love all my senpais
All my senpais
Well, you'll leave us with food while you're away, of course, it'll be a little automatic Spencer
All your favorite
Um what else
Yeah
I can let you all be free, of course so you can just
You know wander but as well
Uh
Watch for other senpais and maybe me who knows I'll be behind your back
If any wandering eyes or
If you start, you know having thoughts about not coming back or anything
That might be an issue right especially the not coming back stuff
If you don't come back
How can I show you my love and how can we have fun together and how can we spend eternity together?
That's not possible is it if you're we're gone, but if you want to be gone forever, I can have that arranged senpai
I can have that arranged for you to be gone forever. It just requires a little barrel a little acid and
You know a bone saw
But I can have you be gone forever if that's what you want if that's what you truly want
So don't worry
Don't worry senpai. I'll have everything off under control for you
Okay, okay, okay
Senpai, senpai. Oh, thank you Raoul or kiss for
becoming a snippet member and
make me please thank you for the
Ten ten super I I can fix her
Why would you need fixing? Why would I why would you want to be fixed? I can break you
Senpai
Thank you
Thank you Tagabia for the 420 tip
I can't fix her she can make me worse. I can break you
Or I can make you
Or I can fix you that will be so funny right reverse reverse card. I fix you
I
Fix you let's take ib profen together
It's okay though. I love you even if you're a little broken because all of us are a little broken
That's why we gotta mend our broken broken hearts together
So I back up
Anyways
Anyways, I think we're gonna have a great time
Oh
Wait, what sorry something why is me
My
Come on
I'm gonna fix something I'm gonna fix my schedule a little bit
I'm too addicted to my my games. I can't start another game right now
I gotta finish one of them
I'm gonna fix my schedule I gotta
I gotta put in either another I gotta clear one game
Otherwise, I'll start I'll start I'll start going crazy
Okay
More wild arms Mario, of course, of course, what else would it be?
Thank you so much everyone for joining me today
Uh, thank you so much for all the raids and thank you everyone for joining me
Yes, sorry
Mine mine broken what the hell
Okay, I'm broken suddenly I saw I was like who the fuck is this and why am I subscribed to them
I was like wait, why is my why is my thingy showing me weird stuff? Okay. There we go
Thank you for joining me today. I forgot what I was gonna say. I'm blanking out so hard right now
I think I I'm pretty tired, but we got pretty far in the game and I'm so happy so
Let's see if anyone's on. I don't think anyone's on it's just me and you so therefore I will end the stream
here
So buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
No, since it's my day off tomorrow, you won't see me tomorrow
But you will see me the day after
So screen for mercy
You